luchse und wölfe vor 150 jahren
ausgerottet sind in der schweiz wieder
angekommen und auch einzelne pilot
streifen wieder durch graubünden und das
tessin suchen ein neues revier in einem
alten lebensraum
so funktioniert es nur noch warten
[Musik]
ein film über drei vier fotografen die
luchs wolf und bär seit jahren auf der
spur sind und sich dafür einsetzen dass
die rückkehr wieder heimisch werden
[Musik]
es war im sommer 2006 im vorderen teil
gab es hinweise auf einen ersten
rückkehrenden wolf fotograf peter
dettling hatte wochenlang versucht ihn
zu sehen
noch einmal wollte er eine nacht
durchmachen
ich denke dass ich an den winkel von
landschaften denn der gast aus dem namen
teleobjektiv dummerweise näher
untersucht den fall ihre präsenz auf
gestochen ist zurück zurück auf die
zither gründen heißt der wolf steht
mischa groh wird also denn mitunter
träge peter dettling glückte die erste
fotografie überhaupt eines wild lebenden
wolfes auf schweizer boden
[Musik]
aber für mich sehr wertvoll erfassen
glaube passiert ist und wölfe kommen von
italien her wieder selbst zurück anders
war es bei den luchsen in der
jurassischen gemeinde rekorde hat es
geschneit fotograf florian schießl will
zusammen mit einem befreundeten
wildhüter frische spuren finden sind
recht neugierig also wenn er sich nicht
bedroht fühlt kann es wirklich sein dass
der luchs spaziergängern folgt es sind
wirklich faszinierende tiere im februar
märz ist die beste zeit für
beobachtungen
sie bewegen sich viel und es liegt jetzt
auch guter schnee in den 1970 er jahren
wurde der luchs aktiv wieder angesicht
rund 30 tiere aus den karpaten konnten
sich halten und familien
heute leben in der schweiz etwa 170
thiel
und auch wenn sie manchmal die neugierde
packt luchse sind extrem scheu sie in
freier wildbahn zu fotografieren ist
fast unmöglich
loris long beach los ist trotzdem zu
versuchen
der bretone zug deswegen im jahr 2010
extra in die schweiz
[Musik]
oft bin ich in schwierigem gelände
unterwegs die die tiere mit dem ganzen
material auf dem rücken
35 kilo eineinhalb stunden zu fuß auf
schnee und eis und es ist kalt ist weit
ich sitze dann bis zu vier tage lang
draußen an einem ort ohne zu wissen aber
am schluss ein bild entsteht
zwei lange jahre ging loriot schießler
immer und immer wieder vergebens ins
feld bis er etwas ganz besonderes
erleben durfte
[Musik]
einmal dann tatsächlich da sah ich
während vier tagen ein weibchen mit
ihren drei jungen
wir sind ein paar tolle bilder gelungen
wirklich außergewöhnlich seit seiner
ersten begegnung mit einem wolf oben in
der surselva sind sieben jahre vergangen
es ist 2013 peter dettling beginnt mit
seinen beobachtungen am galander
lebenspartnerin und naturfilme
ringtreffen im uhr ist oft mit dabei er
ist in der zwischenzeit nach kanada
ausgewandert wegen der wolfsfamilie ist
er für einen ersten sommer zurückgekehrt
[Musik]
er findet heraus wo sich ihr kerngebiet
befindet das ist die regel was die
möglichkeit musik punkt finden war nicht
hart 5 hoffentlich beobachtete sich die
störer musste distanz die wolfs mutter
mit beute wie jung ist das rudel
ungestört wirft die wölfin während
jahren am gleichen ort
[Musik]
peter dettling bleibt als beobachter
immer weit von der wurfhöhle entfernt
[Musik]
auf die idee kommt ihn weil er gott zu
reden wir fort die werder macher formen
der vor rändern der wolf oder so ich
habe natürlich das verhalten von der
welt vor einer beobachten dokumentieren
[Musik]
gelegenheit das wolfs verhalten zu
studieren bot sich ihm zuvor in übersee
in einem kanadischen national park drei
jahre lang lebte er nächster nähe zu
einem wolfsrudel
[Musik]
glück hat die richtige lied auch keine
zu lernen wo ganz großes tiefe handy
wird will und in kanada einen deutschen
können klären
sie nahm ist günther bloch und der
person wolfsrudel wollen im portal in
banff national park lebt würde so 15
so beobachtet und dokumentiert und auch
darüber schrieben
[Musik]
jeder taxi-zentrale erklärungsentwurf
als dettlingen zu kommen
bestand die wolfsfamilie aus zwei
jungtieren und dem elternpaar die beiden
forscher gaben ihnen nahmen den vater
hatten sie immer noch die mutter der
linda zuweilen kamen sich wolf und
mensch ganz nah einmal ist ein junger
und der nokia spitze zurück welche
mittel auf distanz sie dass die sachen
die andere ist wirklich rundum jungen
und wieder zu der fotograf wurde auch in
großer nähe nie bedroht wenn st sieht
den hausmeister also die angst vor
mensch ist größer als umgekehrt und wolf
ist für ganz normales krieg vor und ein
toter mensch am nieder
[Musik]
in seinem zweiten jahr war linda wieder
junge und die familie vergrößerte sich
auf 10 tier verschieden jungen geboren
denn die wo das gebäude sind das ist das
typische wolfsfamilie brodelt seit peter
nettling filmte und fotografierte
einzelne ganz verschiedene tiere jedes
tier mit eigenem charakter eigenen
fähigkeiten und bestimmter stellung
innerhalb der familie
er gewann tiefen einblick in das
sozialverhalten der wölfe
es gibt viele bücher sattel war familie
lebe von der rollbahn menschen im
vergleich zum beispiel eine
dokumentierte dass eine verletzte sich
und ein handy under wirklich vorteil
gebracht und überwachen
als wirklich den verein anzeiger das
sind wirklich an soziale tiere und ganz
intelligente tiere
[Musik]
er wollte mehr erfahren und gingen die
usa in den yellowstone park im ältesten
naturschutzpark der welt gab es während
jahrzehnten keine wölfe in den 1990 er
jahren wurden sie wieder angesiedelt
dinge fehlen hatte zu problemen geführt
ganz frei fachseite es wieder zu große
population klarheit und die ganzen
großen negativen einfluss kaufs
ökosystem und pflanzenwelt vor allem und
das hat sich auch negativ ausfällt duft
biodiversität im allgemeinen biber sind
abzüge sind verrät weniger der nächsten
möglichkeit accounts mit und denise
unglaublich also der fluss vom wolf aufs
ganze ökosystem ist viel größer als dass
man denken
eine treibjagd der wölfe
peter dettling konnte mitverfolgen wie
die raubtiere innerhalb von einem
jahrzehnt die zu grossen fischbestände
auf ein natürliches maß reduziert und
die fauna und flora am yellowstone park
wieder in ein größeres gleichgewicht
fanden
[Musik]
das ist natürlich eine andere gegend mit
den vielen menschen natürlich als straße
viel mehr zeit viel mehr schienenverkehr
was auch immer das ist natürlich eine
andere dynamik da aber dass der wolf
fällt dem ökosystem da das kann man sich
sein und jetzt kommt er langsam wieder
zu
[Musik]
wildtier fotografie das heißt zuerst
einmal gar nicht fotografieren sondern
literatur studieren daten auf arbeiten
heißt sich intensiv beschäftigen
lorsch islam wusste dass er sich mit dem
fotografieren von wildlebenden luchsen
offen aufwendiges projekt einlässt das
ist ein projekt für das ich vier
viereinhalb jahre budgetiert habe
eineinhalb jahre steckte ich alleine in
die recherche ich musste mich
einarbeiten in der kartografie musste
lernen wie sie sich bewegen wo sie
überhaupt sind und jetzt das umsetzen in
die praxis sagt komm ich überhaupt zu
fotos oder nicht es gibt sie die
fotografie über
bislang arbeitet eng mit biologen und
wildhütern zusammen und manchmal kann es
ganz schnell gehen
ein luchs ist in eine falle gegangen das
hat einen alarm ausgelöst
eine sms gingen fünf handys an dem
wildhüter die biologen und auch nun alle
gleich hergekommen
damit der luchs nicht lange mit stress
in der kiste bleiben muss der alarm ging
von einer kostenfalle aus von dieser
gelben kiste tatsächlich hat sich ein
luchs durch einen köder hinein locken
lassen
die 170 luchse in der schweiz werden im
auftrag des bundes von einer gruppe
geologen überwacht regisseur arbeitet
für sie als dokumentarist und erhält im
gegenzug exklusive szenen ein schönes
tier wohl ein männchen ziemlich groß
es ist schon ein beeindruckendes tier
ein großes münchen hat 23 24 kilo
das ist wie ein großer hund die leute
stellen sich vor der luchs ist eine
katze aber es ist ein richtiges raubtier
ein grossraubtieren aber trotzdem
absolut ungefährlich wenn er einem
menschen begegnet versteckte sich oder
läuft weg es ist wirklich ein tier das
überhaupt nicht aggressiv ist und nie
willkürlich angreifen würde
auch in der literatur habe ich keinen
einzigen fall gefunden in dem ein luchs
einen menschen attackiert hätten
das männchen wacht auf mit einem sender
am hals unfreiwillig ist er nun einer
von rund 10 luchsen im land die den
forschern ständig verraten wo sie sich
gerade aufhalten
[Musik]
vielleicht mit diesem lux bald etwas
zustoßen dann bin ich froh habe ich
wenigstens die fotos von heute
vielleicht aber findet man ihn in einer
woche bereits 70 kilometer entfernt von
ihr
es soll wirklich eine langfristige
geschichte werden ich hoffe immer auf
geschichten mit fortsetzung
[Musik]
da ist ideal bewirtschaftet auch peter
dettling suchte von anfang an den
austausch mit dem wildhüter mit claudia
spart ihnen geht er durchs kunkels tal
ein rückzugsgebiet der kalender wölfe
es ist spätsommer 2013
beide wissen zur zeit nicht wie groß das
rudel ist und wo sich die tiere
aufhalten
keiner der wölfe trägt einen sender
fotofallen geben den wildhütern
zumindest anhaltspunkte
und wir wollen natürlich besser
ausgefallen sind 250 natürlich qualität
ist nicht überall so wird das gute
qualität das wäre jetzt zwiebel die
fotofallen bilder verwaltet auf bündner
seite jagdinspektor georg brosi der
oberste jäger im kanton angst breit dass
150 jahre lang fehlten die wölfe im
ökosystem jäger und wildhüter sind daran
die rückkehrer wieder kennenzulernen und
herauszufinden was durch ihre
anwesenheit geschieht
da gibt es ja auch positive aspekt wenn
der wolf zurückkommt wenn der sinnlose
hier stellt oder und da fällt natürlich
grossraubtiere wohlstand ist entsprechen
die prüfer des handys mit dem wohl
wieder von der beute die er stellte fest
dass wohl verweigert diese selektiv
konzentriert sich so schwache dem
verletzte der regel viel viel mehr mühe
bis zum see bis denn wirklich als
schwachstelle ist es der auch an alex
ist ein konkurrent der jäger sondern das
wolfsrudel aber ich glaube mit dem
konkurrenten sie einmal vorläufig
mindestens leben retten das einfach
wirklich einmal abwartend verfolgen wie
sich die situation entwickelt
die jäger werden die wolfs präsenz bei
den hirschen wohl erst in ein paar
jahren richtig spüren
anders die schafhalter sie mussten
bereits reagieren
das kontroverse thema beschäftigt auch
peter dettling wolfs präsenz heißt
herdenschutz mehraufwand für hirten und
bauern auf der alp grön des sterns
oberhalb von green wurde vor zwei tagen
ein schaf gerissen
die alb wird seit 2003 von schutzhunden
bewacht
doch die vier hunde bemerkten nichts
unklar ob der ist tatsächlich von einem
wolf stammt
religion ist peter dettling besucht den
hirten jonas ley und seine praktikantin
gabriel wann zelaya sind ja die sind
extrem wochen teile sind die einkünfte
sieht und die andere darunter einige
präsidiert optik und dann ist mir das
häufig gratis an der bisswunde des toten
scharfes namen wildhüter eine
speichelprobe ein dna test soll klären
ob es tatsächlich wolf war mit dem lied
es auch ihn besser und das war genau so
gute frequenz der box ein paar tage
später konnte bescheid
es war kein wolf
der aufwand für den herdenschutz ist
groß jeder albracht gezielte maßnahmen
aber im kalender gebiet funktioniert pro
jahr und ab ging im schnitt nur je ein
schaf an die wölfe verloren
aufgrund des sterns gab es bisher noch
keinen einzigen ries das ist in sieben
neue situationen und jetzt dem gewirr
aus dem sie zehn jahre funktioniert das
also eine figur durch baut und den
anderen art wurde zweifacher bezieht und
und du musst ja unterstützen und so dass
lauf das durch vielleicht ein bisschen
zieht aber das kommt wirklich gut
[Musik]
das warm oder im nationalpark ein teil
durch dass die bären wandern
13 junge menschen streiften in den
letzten jahren durch die schweiz
viele von ihnen kam hier vorbei weitere
werden folgen
joana schönenberger biologin vom wwf
führt fotograf david bittner dorthin wo
die bären herkommen die beiden wollen
ins italienische trentino die grenze
genau den straßen
david miller fotografierte bisher bären
in alaska in der wildnis argentino leben
sie in einer kulturlandschaft
dank wieder ansiedlungen hat sich
neulich des gardasees eine
bärenpopulation gehalten und das
zusammenleben von bär und mensch und
dessen nutztieren kümmern sich 30
ausgewählte bärenhüter im teilzeitpensum
sandra decoux ist einer von ihnen ich
freue mich zu sehen
hoffentlich sehen wir bald auch die
bildung oder der bären mann aus alaska
der bären mann aus dem trentino
zweimal haben wir am hang dort drüben
einen bären gesichtet
beide male früh morgens vielleicht gehen
wieder stillschweigend die fachstelle
für einen rufen auch eine pro forma
europäische grund das thema für mich und
hoffe natürlich dass jetzt eine gute
stelle verraten bekommen nach dieser
rechnung stellen
das ist für die bären der bequemste weg
um nachts von diesem kleinen teil dort
unten ins val konnte sie zukommen
dort sind große schafherden ab und zu
stützt ein schaf ab und stirbt die bären
steigen dann ins tal um es zu fressen
auch es könnte ein bär ganz in der nähe
sein
für seinen ersten besuch und trentino
hat sich david bittner eine woche zeit
genommen dass an diesen sieben tagen
eine mehr sehen wird ist
unwahrscheinlich selbst wenn er ständig
auf beerenfarben geht wenn geht jetzt
ein paar wird oder ob sich so wird ihn
natürlich bemerkbar machen
damit der körper wenn ihr merkt wirklich
teure eigentlich erwartet dass sie
nachher würde mir aus dem weg geht das
normale verhalten eine wirklich macht
oder gar würde ich mit ruhiger stimme
nicht zu geräten um ihr natürlich
entsprechend entfernen damit dadurch
passieren
angst hat die nicht unbedingt sehr viel
begegnung gekommen mit ware aber hat
sichere wahnsinns emotionalen schub
trotzdem will ich natürlich in alaska
und das natürlich schon als unglaublich
so lange sitzen da ist renten oder unter
der dusche stand
super funktioniert jetzt nur noch warten
seit vielen sommern fotografiert david
bittner an einem ort wo er für bären
bilder keine fotofallen braucht an einem
fluss in alaska einem leicht platz der
lachse
[Musik]
er lernt dabei viel über das verhalten
von grizzlys weitab von menschlichen
siedlungen
jetzt interessiert ihn aber wie sich
bären in relativ engem raum mit menschen
verhalten
dort siehst du jeden tag hier ist es
sehr schwierig einen bären zu begegnen
das einzige mal als ich so nahe war dass
ich den bären hätte fotografieren können
war meine kamera kaputt im trentino
haben sich die bären ihr wildtier
verhalten bewahrt
die jungen bärenmännchen jagen nun mal
gerne und suchen sich neue reviere darum
gehen sie zu euch in die schweiz wir
kriegen die schwierigen fälle
die weibchen sind nie das problem drei
problem während wurden im trentino
bisher gefangen und ins gehege genommen
getötet wurde noch kein mehr
die meisten der 50 tiere leben in zwei
nationalparks die jungen menschen aber
sind viel unterwegs suchen ein eigenes
revier
13 von ihnen wurden bisher in der
schweiz gesichtet
zwei von ihnen als problembären
bezeichnet und abgeschossen
[Musik]
es ist traurig dass die bären die in die
schweiz gehen nicht mehr zurückkehren es
bekümmert uns sehr dass unsere wäre
nicht mehr nach hause kommen am nächsten
tag mit der fotofalle hat es nicht
geklappt
david bittner begleitet einen initianten
des bären projekts auf einem
kontrollgang walter karl betty ist fast
jeden tag unterwegs gerät halter von
nutztieren hilft beim bau von
schutzvorrichtungen und vertreibt auch
dreiste jung weniger kommt ein bär in
seiner pubertät wiederholt an eine
siedlung heran dann verbrennt ihn walter
galletti mit gummigeschossen oder
vertreibt ihn mit karelischen bären und
sein eigener bärenjagd und führt ihn
immer wieder zu frischen spuren
ich spaziere mit dem hund an der leine
änderte er die richtung oder bleibt er
stehen
er schnüffelt an etwas herum sieht dann
weiß ich hier ist etwas mit meinem hund
finde ich immer wieder fälle haare oder
kratzen biss der hund ist wie eine sehr
wichtige hilfe nicht nur für die
spurensuche aber vor allem dafür dass
hier sind eindeutig die kratzspuren
stammen von den clown und hier sind
bissspuren hier haben sie die baumrinde
abgerissen wie dort drücken auch dann
drehen sie sich gegen den baum und
kurzen sich den rücken
dieses verhalten kennt david bittner
auch von alaska her
er hat es dort gefilmt
[Musik]
an diesem baum kratzen sie sich oft hier
finde ich immer wieder bären haare ja
mindestens zwei bis drei bären hatten
sich hier ständig auf ein ausgewachsenes
männchen und ein weibchen auch zwei
junge männchen haben hier schon markiert
[Musik]
david bittner versucht es noch einmal
mit der fotofalle und walter kwt
assistiert ihm beiden ist aber klar es
wird wahrscheinlich wieder kein foto
geben weil das wetter hingegen gelangen
in seiner bisher 15 jährigen tätigkeit
immer wieder fotos und filmaufnahmen die
zu wertvollen dokumenten wurden
[Musik]
er zeigt dem besucher aus der schweiz
filmaufnahmen mit einer bärin und zwei
ihrer jungen
die mutter ist eine der umgesiedelten
bärinnen aus slowenien
[Musik]
18 junge hat bären danica bisher geboren
und aufgezogen
sie ist auch die mutter des in der
schweiz erschossenen bären m 13
erst maria im positionen
[Musik]
die fantastic konnte
wie gesagt ganz klar wenn sie bevor sie
ab geeignet ist schluckt sie ihn mit
hintere ist noch da und dort ganz
bewusst den rücken zu ihm
mit dem buch so wie immer
unterschiedlich sondern das ist immer
nur meister schutz junger vorsicht
zahlen der verletzliche position und sie
weiß ganz genau dass er hat gestanden
ist
[Musik]
für mich war es das größte
ich filmte musste aber die kamera auf
dem stativ lassen weil meine hände vor
aufregung zum starten
ich war so aufgewühlt ich hatte ein
riesen glück denn so etwas sieht man
selten
ich war sehr glücklich
[Musik]
für lohr schüßler blieben die direkten
begegnungen mit luchsen selten wird
großem aufwand darum begann auch er
fotofallen einzusetzen
zwei hatte in einem abgelegenen tal
hinter yverdon installiert hier eine
schöne große luke spur
hier kenne ich heißt b158 da ist noch
eine oder ist eine frische spur
wir werden gleich sehen ob es sogar
bilder gegeben hat nein nichts auch wenn
es dieses mal nicht geklappt hat die
fotofalle hat ihn schon die schönsten
bäder gemacht
[Musik]
gleich oberhalb steht der zweite 32
fotos das bedeutet leider nicht 32 look
spieler ein richtiges fotostudio hatte
aufgebaut
nur ich und ein kreuzchen
das ist hart machen wir immer dreck auf
die linse und dann die taugen sie den
platz und bleiben für weiß nicht wie
lange und lösen ständig den apparat aus
ich habe ein loch gegraben das dauerte
drei tage lang in den felsen rein dann
habe ich alle diese großen steine
gesammelt
mittlerweile haben sich die tiere nord
gewöhnt
[Musik]
seine bilder gibt l'orange auch den
biologen die die schweizer luxus
überwachen projektleiter frieder ling
zimmermann sind sie eine willkommene
ergänzung
auch er setzt fotofallen 1 der erste los
den haben wir bereits an einem anderen
ort im winter fotografiert man kann ihn
an seinem fell muster gut wiedererkennen
das war musste ist einfach sicher
geboten das bleibt einfach immer gleich
das haben was ist wenn die daten zu
kommen aber wieder der kann die forscher
verstehen immer besser wie sich die
aktuell 170 luchse in der schweiz
verhalten 60 leben im jura 110 in den
alten die widerstände waren einst groß
doch die risse bei nutztieren blieben
gering so beruhigten sich die gemüter
über die jahre aus dem wallis ist die
wiederansiedlung geglückt aber nach
linie zahlen und man man.etr großes
spiel rum und die population schnell und
schneller von rebecca population
erfahrung und demographischer stark ich
bin noch genetisch tbc dann man von
populationen von musik die rovers buchte
im gesamten alpenraum leben derzeit rund
180 luchse die biologen wünschen weitere
aus siedlungen eine vermehrung auf 1000
tiere eine vernetzung der populationen
von frankreich bis slowenien
dann wäre das leben der schweizer luchse
langfristig gesichert und logis slum
auch er hat beschlossen weiterzumachen
und mit weiteren reportagen einen
beitrag zur vermittlung zu leisten
[Musik]
mit meinen bildern möchte ich die leute
sensibilisieren so dass sie sagen ich
möchte auch dass in meinem wald ein
großes raubtier erlebt
[Musik]
auch im trentino war der erhalt einer
bärenpopulation nur möglich dank viel
aufklärung dank enger zusammenarbeit mit
der bevölkerung und dank der arbeit von
ausgebildeten bärenhüter neofaschist für
das wallis in eller zuständig einem tal
in der nähe der stadt trient er hat bwin
danica besendert es kommt von dort
hinten
anita ist etwa eineinhalb kilometer
entfernt in dieser richtung
das signal ist sehr gut und klar
bevor david bittner noch einmal zwei
tage alleine auf fotopirsch in die berge
geht führen ihnen die bärenhüter zur
höhle wo da nichts an den letzten winter
verbrachte
memory stick okay
also das ist schon spezielles gefühl
dass ich meine das ideale der klasse m
mit jungen und dass man ihm gesagt das
könne nicht der verein kulturlandschaft
männliche hauptstraße 50
also ganz spezielles käufer die sache zu
ende
[Musik]
ja ganz klar
siehst du die wiese dort oben
danica muss gleich dahinter sein hinter
diesem hügel david wir lassen dich jetzt
arbeiten und wünschen dir schöne bilder
viel glück
trotz unterstützung sieht david bittner
kein tier doch es war für ihn eine gute
woche die arbeit der bärenhüter hat ihn
beeindruckt sie persönlich wünscht die
nähe des schwitz vielen aktiven die
rolle würde übernahme im zu machen
einfach mit dem schutz und die förderung
von dem alter und der tatsache dass
fachliche seite sowie die schweiz bleibt
offen den krieg selbst raten die
population oder eben nicht
zurück ins kalender gebiet es ist
frühling 2016 peter dettling beobachtet
die wolfsfamilie bereits im vierten jahr
im herbst zeit dritter zurück und wirkt
das ganze gebiet abwandert und seitun um
15 millimeter jeder tag im gebiet also
wird intensiv zum probiert keiner lerner
natur kennenlernen nur den glauben
erwirbt besser verstehen
ganz klar das sind nochmal
knochensplitter aber sie sind als sie
ganz glauben er hat neue mitverfolgt wie
sich das rudel entwickelte jedes jahr
wanderten einige jungwölfe ab und die
wölfin war wieder junge interessante ist
egal der jahre hat sich sap endeten acht
und zehn tieren also welt tritt ihre die
256 welt
jungwirth vom vorherigen wurde also
ungefähr 8 bis 12 peter dettling folgte
den wölfen durch ihr ganzes revier bis
hoch hinauf auf zweieinhalb tausend
meter höhe und im winter bis hinunter in
die dörfer
wenn hirsche und rehe nachts bis
hinunter ins rheintal kommen
[Musik]
sie können die im winter aber wird aus
schnee arme und hände bis 2 uhr in der
nacht mit trust auf feldern und in die
marke glauben dann wieder zurück und was
macht das ganz genau 18 dynamik school
hauptnahrungsquelle für wolf ist frauen
im winter
und darum sind wir auf den feldern ist
er oft auch über nacht im februar 2016
hatte er zwei kilometer von der stadt
entfernt frühmorgens eine begegnung mit
einem wolf und konnte sie filmen
[Musik]
anfang der mini bemerkt und ich rufe und
auf einmal bemerkt staubli besorgt und
der hd sitzen menschen tatsächlich vor
dass strauß weg und ist eigentlich mini
umgang
also hätten wie ist ausgewichen wie kann
auch mit die heimische viel kredit und
vielen mehr genau wann ich jetzt da
erlebt haben und dokumentiert den vielen
durchlaufzeit genau die gleichen abgang
erfolge aber auch häufig sie hat bislang
ist das bier und das ist das typische
von 12 erwarten mal ist er uns für das
gasthaus auf dem googles was sie vor mit
dem fahrrad richtung pass hoch da
begegnete auch sie einem wolf angst aber
ich verspannen auf sie und den fahrer
werde ich mich und ich sechs sieben
meter vor mir ist er es ausdrückt und
misst vwa durch das hindernis im weg ein
christ und trank mich war das etwas und
ich glaube solche begegnungen haben die
regierungen von krabbelnden und st
gallen aufgelöst und als nicht
tolerierbare ereignisse gewertet dabei
sind auch einige sichtungen nachts in
einem dorf auf grund der liste
bewilligte der bund ende 2015 den
abschuss von zwei jungen wölfen
die zielsetzung muss sie dass mehrere
kairo ist die er in den winter verlegen
konkret zur tageszeit ist nicht
einzeltiere ist die sound wolfsrudel
gewo sich südlichste nachruf halten will
dass leute mir nicht als natürliches
verhalten und wenn holst dir natürlich
erfahrung machen dass sie im mensch kein
hindernis oder sogar schrecknisse gmünd
denn würden sie sich wenn der jugend
wolf nähert passiert denn die eigentlich
immer noch der manager
also ich glaube auch als überspitzte so
formulieren
sowohl von ohne weiters sehr noch
bitterlich lieber für ihn ist das kein
problem
das problem ist eher of the seeker vor
der lueg wir noch an sich dulden sie das
über die welt räumen
die aufgabe an die wildhüter war dann
bei einem der kalender dörfer einer
gruppe wölfe abzupassen und daraus zwei
jungtiere zu schießen
in der hoffnung die überlebenden
einzuschüchtern doch die abschluss frist
verstrich im milden winter 2015/16
hielten sich die wölfe meistens in der
höhe auf
peter dettling ist froh darum
für ihn wäre ein abschuss ein falsches
mittel
er findet nochmals diskutieren ob aktive
vertreibung nötig sind
und wenn ja wo und mit welchen mitteln
derweilen geht er weiterhin ins wolffs
revier und hält seine beobachtung fest
wie hier ein riss an games er macht
weiter mit feldforschung und vermittlung
der fotograf muss ich sagen ist es gab
eine wolfs wolf fotografie als hobby
betrieben ist das kein guter hardware
markiert sie so wenig dass man auch gut
fotografieren
diese distanz es aussieht muss sich ab
und zu hören aber zum gut gemacht ist
das nicht trotzdem für mich ist das ja
nicht nur fotografie projekt verhalten
vorwirft richtig keiner lernen damit ich
mich einsetze zu zeigen
das ist eine gute sache dass man doch
wieder spielzeit und ich zehn jahren
abgeschlossen
[Musik]